je m'appelle vraiment merci madame je
viens de monaco générale 2010 donc je
suis arrivé en france et bientôt à sa
fin huit mois avant j'étais d'alary j'ai
fait la demande
de quoi russe pour la minorité dont ils
sont pas mal c'était pour ma maison
était donc je me suis allé à msf
dépasser jour là ils sont comment ça
m'aide
[Musique]
parce que ça que j'ai entendu les gens
qu'ils ont dit pour le moment c'est un
accident c'est bon le jul 20th été aussi
c'est pas bon ils vont te demander de
faire les tests déjà il y en ad gisent
aussi qui font pas tout ça depuis ta
plume mesure devons voir des actes de
naissance du roi tape c'était il y en a
des zizou aussi bon en vente prendre
beaucoup d'états il y en a déjà regardé
soit six mois des tests de temps avec
des naissances avec les tests des autres
après ils vont décider ce qu'ils auront
le vent
[Musique]
à
oh
[Musique]
il a réussi à l'heure où le troll 1 c2
qui puisse se poser se reposer accès
accéder à une alimentation correcte
c'est laver laver ses affaires se sentir
en sécurité est ce qui évidemment pas le
cas lors c'était avant dans la rue et
puis aussi on peut fonctionner à des
activités collectives notamment des
cours de français qui sont proposés et
puis notre sortie au musée
[Musique]
c'est une belle rencontre des liens qui
continue à perdurer
et on a aussi quelques exemples où des
familles qui ont accueilli des jeunes
une fois que le jeune a été reconnue
mineurs se sont positionnés et ont fait
le choix d'accueillir le jeune ensuite
au sein de leur propre famille
[Musique]
les demandes et un gamin d'aller
expliquer qu'il a été torturé voire dieu
les voir kidnappés sur son parcours
inutile de vous dire qu'il ment il va
pas le dire son fiel sont fragiles ils
n'osent pas parler de ça nous nous
arrivons à les faire parler mais parce
que on a des psychologues
nous avons des médecins attentif il ça
prend des semaines et il parle de la
souffrance et de la maltraitance qu'ils
subissent en france qui finalement là la
pire des souffrances parce qu'ils se
croyaient enfin arrivés au terme de leur
voyage il a une découvrent que leur
voyage là malheureusement ce n'est pas
un doux rêve
c'est un gros cochelard
[Musique]
déjà pour avoir été juge ça prend des
mois vous avez des juges bienveillant
vous avez des juges
on va dire par très bienveillant qui ont
pas du tout de se casser la tête qui ne
reçoivent même pas les gamins et qui
décide que finalement ils sont majeurs
et en fonction des décisions des juges
il faut repartir dans un long combat
pour faire certifier les documents par
exemple
tout est fait finalement complexifier
d'accès à la justice et au point d être
un peu beaucoup de choses par rapport à
mon avis ce que j'ai et rêve de le faire
donc je suis point de commencer de le
faire demain
[Musique]